hey everyone we're the cast of Marvel
Studios black panther wakanda forever
and today we'll find out which one of us
knows how cast made the best and guess
who's going to win I am please let the
guessing begin
[Music]
this person has an Ivy League education
from Cornell I know this answer Hugo
Hugo Dominique I'm going to go with
Angela Bassett Winston Patricia Ray it's
Dominique
because she kept talking about it on set
to be Ungifted and black though right
this person has nearly 70 acting credits
wow wow to Noche it's definitely Angela
Bassett Angela Bassett I think that
might be me this has got to be Miss
Angela Bassett I'm gonna say it's to
notch whoa Angela the passive oh
you got me man
you pulled away this person is also a
doctor
what sort of doctor has to be a PhD
that's Angela Bassett it might be me
I am a doctor I have five doctorates
it's true though right don't hate the
player you fall-headed demons show some
respect you
this person appeared on an episode of
Doctor Who well it's not you that's good
uh Winston I'll say Leticia can I guess
yeah I think it's Michaela Cole Leticia
Wright I'm going to agree who is it
thank you
amazing come learn more about the next
chapter of our characters in Black
Panther wakanda forever only in theaters
November 11th
[Applause]